well I disagree that the Democratic
Party should be a party of litmus tests
and in the past we were in the past we
said the litmus tests are you can't be
against gun control that you had to be
pro-choice now I'm pro-choice but I'm
also somebody that respects the Second
Amendment and and and the Democratic
Party used to have other litmus tests
that tended to favor a party dominated
in the Northeast and the Far West and in
between the Iowas the New Mexico is the
southwest the Florida's the Ohio's they
were kind of left out and so right now i
believe the Democratic Party is is in a
good healthy state well I disagree with
almost everything I mean the fact that
they are so wedded to the past than the
war they each won a trumpet how great
the surge is working there intolerant
rent on immigration they don't want to
change the health care system in this
country I guess what i like about the
republican party I like the people that
represented it in the past I am a great
admirer of Abraham Lincoln and Teddy
Roosevelt who were at the time
conservationists and I believe that if
you're going to be an environmental
president you have to build bipartisan
support and Teddy Roosevelt was able to
do that Lincoln you know he's the man
that end its labor he was a Republican
so I believe that it's important that we
develop bipartisan solutions what I
would do as president is I'll have a
bipartisan cabinet Republicans
independents and Democrats I won't over
do all the Republicans but but that's
supposed to be funny but what I'm saying
is that I think we need a new way of
governing than signals to the American
people that we need to bring everybody
together
you